let's take the derivative of of well
well
we're let's prove what the derivative of
e to the x is and and i think that this
is one of the most amazing things
depending on how you view it about
either calculus or math or the universe
so we want to figure out well we're
essentially going to prove we we've i've
already told you before that the
derivative
of e to the x is equal to e to the x
which is amazing the slope at any point
of that line is equal to
the x value uh is equal to the function
at that point not the x value
either the slope at any point is equal
to that that that is mind-boggling so
you could take and that also means that
the second derivative at any point is
equal to the function of that value or
the third derivative or the infinite
derivative and that that doesn't that
never ceases to amaze me but anyway back
to work so how we're going to prove this
well we already proved i actually just
did it right before starting this video
that the derivative
and some some people actually call this
the definition of e they go the other
way around they say there's some number
for which this is true and we call that
number e so you it can almost be viewed
as a little bit circular but we've we've
shown e in the past to be what happens
when you get you know we said that e is
equal to the limit
as n approaches infinity of 1 over 1
plus n
to the n and then using this we actually
proved that the derivative of ln
of x is equal to 1 over x right the
derivative of log base e of x is equal
to 1 over x so now that we prove this
out
let's use this to prove this
so let's take the derivative
let's let me keep switching colors to
keep it interesting let's take the
derivative
of
ln
of e to the x
well this is and this is almost trivial
this is equal to
well you know the the logarithm of a to
the b is equal to b times the logarithm
of a so this is equal to the derivative
of x
ln of e
and this is just saying e to what power
is equal to e well to the first power
right so this just equals the derivative
of x which we have shown is equal to one
i think we have shown it hopefully we've
shown it
if we haven't that's actually a very
easy one to prove
okay fair enough we we we did that
but let's let's do this another way
let's use the chain rule
right
so what does the chain rule say if we
have f of g of x where we have one
function embedded of another one the
chain rule says we take the derivative
of the inside function
the derivative of the inside function so
d
x
of
e to the x
and then we take it the derivative of
the outside function or the derivative
of the outside function with respect to
the inner function you can almost view
that way and then that is equal to so
the derivative of ln of e e to the x
with respect to e to the x that's a
little confusing you could have written
a d e to the x down over here but i
think you know the chain rule by now
that is equal to
1 over e to the x and that just comes
from this
right but instead of an x we have an e
to the x so this is just the chain rule
right
well what else do we know we know that
this is equal to this
and we also know that this is equal to
this
so this must be equal to this so this
must be equal to one
well let's just multiply both sides of
this equation by e to the x
well we'll get a
we get on the left hand side we're just
left with this expression
the derivative
of e to the x
times we multiply we're multiplying both
sides by e to the x times e to the x
over e to the x i just chose to put the
e to the x on this term
is equal to
e to the x this is 1 right
scratch it out
we're done
that might not not have been completely
satisfying for you but it works
the derivative
of e to the x is equal to e to the x
that i mean i i think i think i think
we the school or the nation should
should take a a national holiday or
something and people should just ponder
this
because it's it really is fascinating
but actually this will lead us to to
even i i would say even more dramatic
results in the not too
far off future anyway i'll see in the
next video